ASSEMBLY MEMBER FLORIDA NOTICES
THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM.
SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL PREPARE
THE CHAMBER AND BRING IN THE
ABSENT MEMBERS AND THE CLERK
WILL CALL THE ROLL. I AGREE ARE
CURRY. ARAMBULA BARRICADE HAND
BENNETT BERMAN BIGELOW BLOOM
BOERNER HORVATH BRIAN BURKE
CALDERON CARRILLO CERVANTES
CHAU CHEN TO CHOI COOLEY COOPER
CUNNINGHAM DALY DALY DAVIES
FLORA FONG FRAZIER FRIEDMAN
GABRIEL GALLAGHER CRISTINA
GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA GIPSON
GONZALEZ GRAY GRAYSON HOLDEN
IRWIN JONES SAWYER KALRA KILEY
LACKEY LEAD. LEVINE LOW
MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS MAYES
MCCARTY MEDINA MULLIN
MURATSUCHI IN THIS AREA WHEN
O'DONNELL RISIN THREE NORRIS
COURT X. SILVA RAMOS RAY IS
THREE OF US ROBERT RIVAS
RODRIGUEZ RUBIO SALAS SANTIAGO
SAY ARTURO SMITH STONE OBTAINED
VALID THERE IS V. APPROVED VIA
VOEPEL WALDRON WARD WEBER WICKS
WORD MISTER SPEAKER.
MEMBERS A
QUORUM IS PRESENT. A QUORUM IS
PRESENT IN THE ASSEMBLY. WE ASK
OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS IN THE
REAR OF THE CHAMBER. AND IN THE
GALLERY TO PLEASE STAND FOR THE
PRAYER. TODAY'S PRAYER WILL BE
OFFERED BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER TIM
GRAYSON ASSEMBLY MEMBER GRAYSON.
LET US PRAY. GOD IN HEAVEN WE
THANK YOU FOR THIS DAY WE WILL
REJOICE AND WE WILL BE GLAD IN
IT WE PRAY FOR WISDOM GOOD
JUDGMENT THAN GUIDANCE IN THE
BUSINESS OF THE DAY IN YOUR
NAME I'M IN. THANK YOU MISS
GRAYSON WE ASK OUR GUESTS AND
VISITORS TO REMAIN STANDING AND
JOIN US FOR THE FLAG SALUTE
PLEASE JOIN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
DALLY. AS HE LEADS US IN THE
PLEDGE MISTER. MEMBERS PLEASE
JOIN ME. I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE.
THANK YOU MAY BE SEATED.
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL ASSEMBLY GERMAN
SACRAMENTO TUESDAY MAY FOURTH
TWENTY TWENTY ONE THE ASSEMBLY
MINUTE SEVEN AM THE AUDIBLE
PASCHAL DONOHOE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SEVEN IF THIS WERE PRESIDING
CHIEF CLERK SHE PART OF THE
BEST READING FOR DAVID BOWMAN
READING ROLL CALL THE FOLLOWING
YOUR QUESTION HOW MOVES AND
MISTER FLORA SECONDS THAT THE
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL BE DISPENSED WITH.
PRESENTATIONS OF PETITIONS
THERE ARE NONE INTRODUCTION AND
REFERENCE OF BILLS WILL BE
DEFERRED. REPORTS OF COMMITTEES
WILL BE DEEMED READ AND
AMENDMENTS DEEMED ADOPTED.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR
THERE ARE NONE MESSAGES FROM
THE SENATE. THERE ARE NONE
MOVING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS THERE ARE NO
ABSENCES FOR THE DAY. HEY
MISTER CHOW YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
FOR YOUR PROCEDURAL MOTIONS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPENDASSEMBLY
RULE FORTY FIVE POINT FIVE TO
ALLOW ASSEMBLY MEMBERS SALAS
AND ARAMBULA TO SPEAK ON
INDETERMINATE MEMORY TODAY
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER. I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND ASSEMBLY
RULE FIFTY SIX TO ALLOW THE
FOLLOWING COMMITTEES TO NOTICE
BILLSPENDING RE REFER ALL FROM
THE OTHER COMMITTEES. TO ALLOW
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE TO
NOTICE S. B. EIGHT TWENTY ONE
BY SENATE NATURAL RESOURCES AND
WATER COMMITTEE FOR THEIR
HEARING ON WEDNESDAY JULY SEVEN
PENDING RE REFER ALL FROM THE
WATER PARKS AND WILDLIFE
COMMITTEE. WITHOUT OBJECTION
SUCH SHALL BE THE ORDER. I MOVE
TO SUSPEND THE RULES TO
WITHDRAW SB ONE FIFTY ONE SB
ONE FIFTY SEVEN AND SB ONE
FIFTY NINE FROM THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE AND ALLOW ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ATTAIN TO TAKE UP THE
BILLS TODAY WITHOUT REFERENCE
TO FILE FOR THE PURPOSE OF.
THIRD READING. MR FLOOR FOR
PURPOSE WE WITHHOLD UNANIMOUS
CONSENT NATURAL CALL VOTE MR
FLOOR AS WITHHOLDING UNANIMOUS
CONSENT. MISTER CHOW MOVES AND
MISTER GIBSON SECONDS. ON THE
RULES SUSPENSION MEMBERS THIS
IS A PROCEDURAL VOTE THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE MR CHOW IS
ASKING FOR AN AYE VOTE AND MR
FLORA IS ASKING FOR A NO. VOTE
THIS TAKES FORTY IN A SEVENTY
NINE MEMBER HOUSE ON THE RULES
SUSPENSION. SURE SHALL IS
ASKING FOR AND I AM MISTER
FLORA NO. THIS IS PROCEDURAL.
CLARK WELL CLOSE ROLL EYES
FORTY TWO KNOWS FIFTEEN THE
RULES ARE SUSPENDED.
MEMBERS WE
ARE GOING TO MOVE TO BUSINESS
ON THE DAILY FILE. THIS IS
BUSINESS ON THE DAILY FILE.
SECOND READING CLERK WILL READ.
SENATE BILL. TWENTY FOUR TO
FOURTEEN THREE OH EIGHT THREE
FIFTEEN THREE FORTY SEVEN THREE
FIFTY THREE FOUR SEVEN NINE
FIVE FORTY FOUR FIVE SIXTY FOUR
FIVE EIGHTY ONE SIX FORTY SEVEN
A 1-709-822-2973. SEVEN FOUR
THREE THREE THREE FOUR THIRTY
SEVEN FIVE SIXTY SEVEN MM IT'S
IMPORTANT TO REMEMBER IT'S
EIGHTY ONE WITH IMMENSE. FIVE
NINETY WITH A MOMENT SEVEN
FIFTY TO THE MEMBERS IT AWAY
WITH A MOMENT SEVENTEEN WITH A
MEMBERS FIVE TWO ONE OF THE
MEMBERS SEVENTY TWO WITH A
MEMBERS FOR TWENTY THREE WITH A
MINUTES AND SENATE BILL FIVE
THIRTY THREE WITH A MENACE. ALL
BILLS WILL BE DEEMED READ AND
AMENDMENTS DEEMED ADOPTED. THEN
MR CHOW YOU'RE AGAIN RECOGNIZED
FOR YOUR PROCEDURAL MOTION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER AT THE REQUEST OF THE
AUTHOR PLEASE MOVE SB FIVE
EIGHTY ONE ATKINS TO THE
INACTIVE FILE. THE CLERK WILL
NOTE AT THE REQUEST OF THE
AUTHOR PLEASE REMOVE SB SEVEN
OH NINE DOLLY FROM THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. CLICK WILL AGAIN NOTE.
MISTER SHALL YOUR AGAIN
RECOGNIZE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER SPEAKER I MOVE TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE SIXTY
THREE AND SEVENTY SEVEN TO
ALLOW ASSEMBLY MEMBER TEAM TO
TAKE UP THE FOLLOWING BILLS
WITHOUT REFERENCE TO FILE FOR
THE PURPOSE OF CONCURRENCE IN
SENATE AMENDMENTS AB ONE THIRTY
FOUR AB ONE THIRTY SEVEN AND AB
ONE THIRTY EIGHT. I THINK WE
SHALL MISTER FLOOR FOR WHAT
PURPOSE SIR WE WITHHOLD IN
ASKING SINISTRAL CALL VOTE.
MISTER FLORA IS WITHHOLDING
MISTER CHOW MOVES MISTER GIPSON
SECONDS ON THE ROLE SUSPENSION.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE
MEMBERS THIS IS A PROCEDURAL
VOTE. MISTER CHOW IS ASKING FOR
AN I. THE- MISTER FLORA IS
ASKING FOR A NO VOTE.
MISTER
CHAZ ASKING FOR NIGHT MISTER
FLOOR NOTICE A PROCEDURAL VOTE
CLERK WILL. CLOSE ROLE AS FIFTY
ONE NO SIXTEEN. THE RULES ARE
SUSPENDED.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING
TO BE TAKING UP. BUDGET ITEMS.
MEMBERS. WITHOUT REFERENCE TO
FILE WE ARE GOING TO BE TAKING
UP SENATE BILL. ONE FIFTY NINE.
MISTER CHANG THIS IS SENATE
BILL. ONE FIVE NINE. LET'S
PAUSE FOR A MOMENT THIS IS
WITHOUT REFERENCE TO FILE
SENATE BILL.
ONE FIFTY NINE.
MEMBERS THIS IS SENATE BILL ONE
FIFTY NINE WITHOUT REFERENCE
THE FILE SB ONE FIFTY NINE AND
THE CLERK. WILL READ MEMBERS
MEMBERS. THE GREAT SENATE BILL
ONE FIFTY NINE BY THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON BUDGET AND FISCAL
REVIEW AN ACT RELATING TO STATE
EMPLOYMENT MAKING APPROPRIATION
THEREFORE TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY BE RELATED TO THE
BUDGET MISTER TENURE MAILBOX
THANK YOU THAT'S RIGHT WITH
THIS RATIFIES THE MO YOU WITH
MARKETING YOUR SIX WHICH IS THE
CORRECTIONS OF THE CALIFORNIA
CORRECTIONAL PEACE OFFICERS
ASSOCIATION IN APPROVED.
RESTORATION OF SALARY CUTS
WHICH WERE AGREED UPON DURING
THIS LAST YEAR DURING WHAT WE
BELIEVED WAS GOING TO BE A VERY
DIFFICULT BUDGET YEAR IT ALSO
REINSTATES THE POLICE MONTHLY
CONTRIBUTIONS FOR PRE FUNDING
OTHER POST EMPLOYMENT BENEFITS
FROM TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO-
PROVIDES. A SLIGHT A SALARY
INCREASE THAT WAS PRE AGREED
UPON WITH THE ADMINISTRATION
AND PROVIDES COULD TENUOUS
APPROPRIATION FOR FISCAL YEAR
TWENTY TWENTY THREE TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR TO EXTEND THE TERMS
OF THE MO YOU. CAN TELL THE
BUDGET. ACT OF TWENTY TWENTY
THREE. IS ENACTED. THIS SON.
THAT'S THAT'S THAT'S THE BILL
PLEASE THE. THANK YOU THEY
ARRESTING MR FONG WE ARE
RECOGNIZED I THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AS WITH THE PRIOR MO
YOU BUILT LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS SEVEN DOOR TO AN
EXTREMELY EXTRAORDINARY AND
EXTREMELY DEMANDING YEAR AND
OUR CORRECTIONAL OFFICERS HAVE
CERTAINLY FACED TREMENDOUS
CHALLENGES AS COVER NINETEEN
HIT OUR CORRECTIONAL FACILITIES
EXPRESSION. EXPRESSION A SEX.
ESPECIALLY HARD. THIS MO YOU
RESTORES A PAY CUT THEY TOOK
AND PROVIDES NEEDED ACCESS TO
MENTAL HEALTH RESOURCES ACTORS
AND I'VE OUT. THANK YOU MISTER
FOR MISTER JONES SAWYER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. AS PROBABLY MANY OF
YOU KNOW ESPECIALLY THOSE FROM
SEVEN CALIFORNIA. I'M PROBABLY
IF NOT. ONE THAT SHOULD VOTE NO
ON THIS. I PROBABLY HAVE MORE
REASONS. PROBABLY A COUPLE
MILLION REASONS WHY I SHOULD
VOTE NO ON THIS. BUT I'M ALSO
AN SEIU MEMBER. WHEN I WAS WITH
THE CITY OF LA WHEN WE WENT
THROUGH HARD BUDGET TIMES AS A
UNION MEMBER I REMEMBER TAKING
CUTS SUSPENDING OUR SALARIES
FOR LIKE THREE YEARS TO HELP
THE CITY OF LA TO GET OVER OUR
HARSH BUDGET IMPASSE. LUCKILY
FOR US THAT FIFTY SIXTY BILLION
DOLLAR HOLE THAT WE WERE
SUPPOSED TO BEGIN RIGHT NOW.
NOT ONLY DIDN'T HAPPEN BUT
WE'RE FLOURISHING RIGHT NOW.
BOB AS MANY OF YOU FROM
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA. NO THAT.
THERE WAS A LOT STUFF DONE TO
ME. AND SOME OF YOU THOUGHT MY
OPPONENT WAS RUNNING AGAINST
YOU YOU GOT SO MUCH MAIL. BUT
AT THE END OF THE DAY. IT'S
ABOUT SOMETIMES. TURNING THE
OTHER CHEEK SO WE CAN MOVE
FORWARD ESPECIALLY WHEN PEOPLE
DO THE RIGHT THING AND WE
SHOULD PRAISE ALL THE PUBLIC
SECTOR UNIONS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA FOR TAKING THAT RISK
TO SUSPEND SALARIES TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE WERE HOLE. I DON'T
THINK WE DID I DON'T THINK WE
WERE GIVEN UP OUR SALARIES. I
DON'T THINK WE ARE NOT TAKING
BENEFITS TO MAKE SURE. THAT THE
STATE AND THE TAXPAYERS. AND
THAT THE GOVERNMENT WOULD
CONTINUE TO RUN. AND SO I'M
GOING TO GO AHEAD. AND BOAT HI
ON THIS. AND I HAVE ANOTHER
REASON FOR DOING THIS. MENTAL
HEALTH FOR ME IS REALLY
IMPORTANT AND THERE'S SOME
THINGS IN THIS CONTRACT THEY
HELP INDIVIDUALS S. C. C. P.
AWAY DEAL WITH THEIR MENTAL
HEALTH CHALLENGES. WHICH HAS
PRODUCED A LOT OF THE PROBLEMS
THAT WE SEE NCDC ARE. WEATHER'S
DAYS OFF. OR WHETHER IT'S BEING
ABLE TO HAVE MORE DAYS TO DEAL
WITH THE PANDEMIC MENTALLY. I
HAD A BILL ON THIS FLOOR. ABOUT
MENTAL HEALTH FOR PRISON GUARD
TO CCPOA DID MAKE IT THROUGH.
BUT I THINK WE NEED TO BRING IT
BACK NEXT YEAR I NEED TO HAVE
EVERYBODY ON BOARD BECAUSE.
LAST FRIDAY. MANY OF YOU KNOW
STEPHAN WALKER. AND HIS SON
WHO'S A PRO OFTEN CDC ARE
COMMITTED SUICIDE. INSTEAD FOR
WALKERS A FRIEND. OF EVERYBODY
ON THIS FOR SEVERAL WATER IS
THE ONE THAT GAVE ME THAT IDEA.
IT WAS THE WISDOM OF OUR I'VE
MISSED OUT MY FRIEND FROM FROM
A L. DROVE THAT PUT IN THERE
THAT HAVE TO BE PART OF
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING I WISH WE
COULD PUT THIS IN THIS BUDGET
RIGHT NOW. TO DO IT. BECAUSE
IT'S REALLY REALLY IMPORTANT.
AND SO AS WE MOVE FORWARD WITH
THIS. WE NEED TO USE THIS THESE
CONTRACT. TO HELP THEM MOVE TO
THE NEXT LEVEL AND TO HELP THEM
HELP THEMSELVES AND AS I DO
BRING THIS BACK ABOUT MENTAL
HEALTH HOPEFULLY WE CAN DO AN
URGENCY CLAUSE WE CAN DO
WHATEVER WE CAN. ON THE- BUDGET.
AND IN STATUTE. SO THAT WE CAN
MOVE THEM TO THE NEXT LEVEL
I'VE GOT ASSURANCES FROM CCPOA
MANAGEMENT THAT THIS IS REALLY
REALLY IMPORTANT. AND SO I AM
GOING UP TODAY. BUT WE NEED TO
CONTINUE TO STAY VIGILANT
WHAT'S CCPOA SO WE CAN HELP
THEM HELP THEMSELVES. ARE
PROBABLY ONE OF THE TOUGHEST
BEAT YOU CAN WALK IN
CALIFORNIA. OTHERWISE RIGHT NOW
THEY'RE MORE PEOPLE COMMITTING
SUICIDE AND CCPOA IN
CORRECTIONS FACILITIES. BEN
BEING HURT OR KILLED BY
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
INCARCERATED. AND SO THERE'S A
THERE'S A CRISIS THERE. SO FOR
NOW LET'S GO AHEAD AND REALLY
LOOK AT HONORING THE COMMITMENT
WE MADE. DURING A TOUGH TIME TO
THEM. BUT YOU KNOW I WILL TELL
YOU GOD ONLY GIVES PEOPLE TO
CHEEKS. AND YES I'M A TURN TO
CHEAT ON THIS ONE. I ONLY HAVE
ONE OTHER CHEEK. AND I THINK WE
NEED TO UNDERSTAND. AND MAKE
THEM UNDERSTAND. THAT YOU ONLY
GET A COUPLE SHIFTS YOU ONLY
GET ONE CHANCE TO DO MAKE A
MISTAKE NOW'S THE TIME TO MOVE
FORWARD TO MAKE CCPOA BETTER.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISS JONES
SAWYER MISTER KALRA. YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN I APPRECIATE THE
COMMENTS OF MY COLLEAGUE LOS
ANGELES- AND I AGREE WITH WHAT
WITH MUCH OF WHAT HE SAID-
PARTICULARLY. THE LAST PORTION
REGARDING- THE TRAUMA. IN THE
ENVIRONMENTS BURKE OF
CORRECTIONAL FACILITIES THERE'S
TRAUMA FOR CORRECTIONAL
OFFICERS THERE'S TRAUMA FOR
THOSE THAT ARE INCARCERATED-
AND FOR ALL THE OTHERS THAT
WORK IN THOSE FACILITIES AND SO
I WOULD HOPE. AS WE MOVE
FORWARD WE THINK ABOUT WHAT WE
CAN DO TO REDUCE THE TRAUMA
ACROSS THE BOARD FOR EVERYONE
THAT'S INVOLVED OUR SYSTEM
INCLUDING OUR CORRECTIONAL
OFFICERS AND I AGREE THAT
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT WE
PROBABLY SHOULD'VE. DONE A LONG
TIME AGO- IN ADDITION YOU KNOW
LOOK I BELIEVE IN COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING- AND I BELIEVE- IN
PUBLIC WORK IT AND THE WORK OF
THOSE UP WITH THAT ARE IN EVERY
ASPECT OF OUR PUBLIC SERVICE.
AND IF YOU THINK ABOUT OUR
CORRECTIONAL FACILITIES ARE A
LOT OF BARGAINING UNITS THAT
HELP TO RUN THOSE FACILITIES
AND SO WHAT IF THIS PARTICULAR
MEASURES APPROVED. I WOULD HOPE
THAT WE THINK ABOUT ALL OF
THOSE THAT WORK NOT JUST IN
CORRECTIONAL FACILITIES BUT IN
ALL PUBLIC INSTITUTIONS BECAUSE
THEY'VE ALL SACRIFICED- OVER
THE PAST YEAR PLUS EVERYONE TO
SACRIFICE NOT ONLY IN TERMS OF
MONETARILY BUT IN TERMS OF THE
MOTIONAL PHYSICAL MEDICAL
TRAUMA THAT. EVERYONE THAT'S
BEEN REQUIRED TO GO TO WORK
EVERY SINGLE DAY HAS GONE
THROUGH AND I THINK THAT DOES
THAT TO CHOOSE PUBLIC WORK AND
PUBLIC SERVICE DESERVE THE
OPPORTUNITY- TO BE RECOGNIZED
FOR THEIR SACRIFICES AND SO
I'LL BE SUPPORTING THIS
PARTICULAR MEASURE BY ALSO
WOULD URGE ALL OF US TO NOT
FORGET- THE DOZENS AND DOZENS
AND DOZENS OF BARGAINING UNITS
ACROSS- WIDE RANGES OF. OUR
PUBLIC SECTOR SYSTEM. ACTIONS
UNIVERSE CAL. HEALTH AND
HOSPITAL SYSTEMS ACROSS THE
BOARD- MANY OF WHICH WE'VE
SACRIFICED AND WORKED. THROUGH
OF THE PANDEMIC. OF THAT WE
THINK ABOUT THEM AS WELL WHEN
THEY COME FORWARD. AND ASK. FOR
THEIR NOT JUST- COMPENSATION
FOR WHAT THEY SACRIFICE WHAT
THEY GAVE UP TO KEEP THE STATE
AFLOAT- BUT RECOGNITION FOR
THEIR CONTINUED SERVICE IN THE
YEARS AHEAD THANK YOU. AVERAGE
CAR MISTER FLORES. YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I RISE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS AND I JUST WANT
TO SAY A FEW WORDS AND I LINE
MY COMMENTS WITH THE MEMBER
FROM LA. ON THE MENTAL HEALTH
SIDE OF THIS THING. FOR MANY
YEARS. WE UNDERSTAND THAT
MENTAL HEALTH WITH IN PUBLIC
SAFETY WHETHER TO FIREFIGHTER
LAW ENFORCEMENT CCPOA HAS BEEN
A HUGE ISSUE. HOW CAN WE AS AN
INSTITUTION EXPECT THESE MEN
AND WOMEN WHO GO TO WORK EVERY
DAY TO PROTECT US IF THEY ARE
NOT MENTALLY SOUND. HOW CAN WE
EXPECT THEM TO DO THEIR JOBS IN
AND DO THEIR JOBS PROPERLY. SO
I RISE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THIS BUT THIS IS NOT DONE YET.
WE DO A LOT MORE WORK THAT
NEEDS TO BE DONE IN THIS AREA
WE'RE DOING A LOT ON THE
DEVELOPMENTALLY DISABLED. NOW
WE NEED TO FOCUS ON MEN AND
WOMEN TO PROTECT US AND THEIR
MENTAL HEALTH BECAUSE OF THEIR
NOT SOUND. AND WE CAN EXPECT TO
PROTECT US IN THE WAY THAT WE
KNOW THEY WANT TO STOP BY-
TONIGHT VOTE. AND TO THE LOSS
WITHIN CCPO WAYS COMMUNITY- YOU
HAVE OUR SYMPATHY. OUR
CONDOLENCES AND WE'RE HERE TO
FIGHT FOR YOU ON THE MENTAL
HEALTH SIDE OF THINGS WITH
RICHARD. MISS WALDRON. YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MR
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS JUST.
BRIEFLY I. I ALSO- RESPOND TO
ALL A COMMON SET OF MAY. HAVE
BEEN MADE. AND I THINK EVERYONE
IN THIS BODY KNOWS HOW I'VE
BEEN ADVOCATING. FOR SAFETY
MEASURES AND IMPROVEMENTS IN
OUR OWN CAR SCHOOL FACILITIES
FOR YEARS IN FACT. THE
CALIFORNIA EMERGENCY RESPONSE
ACT WAS THE BUDGET S. THIS.
PAST YEAR THAT I HAD. FOR A-
APPROVING. THE DILAPIDATED
FACILITIES THAT WE CALL OUR
CALIFORNIA PRISON SYSTEM- THE
LACK OF RESOURCES A LACK OF
HELP WHICH IS NOT ONLY FOR
THOSE WHO ARE INCARCERATED. BUT
ALSO OF THOSE WHO WORK THERE.
AS WAS MENTIONED BEFORE. THE
STRESSES OF THE MENTAL ANGUISH
THE CONDITIONS IN OUR PRISON
SYSTEMS. NEED TO BE ADDRESSED-
THIS IS ONE STEP. BUT YOU KNOW
WE NEED TO DO A LOT MORE TO
IMPROVE THE LIVES OF THE PEOPLE
WHO WORK IN THOSE FACILITIES.
AN ICE ALWAYS STAND TO ADVOCATE
FOR THAT AND WE'LL WORK ON THAT
SAFETY WITH COLVIN. RUNNING
RAMPANT THROUGH THE OUR CAR SO
FACILITIES- YOU KNOW THAT WAS
SOMETHING WE KNEW WAS COMING
EARLY ON WAS NOT ADDRESSED. BY
THE ADMINISTRATION BUT I FEEL
LIKE. YOU KNOW FINALLY. WE
RECOGNIZE THE PROBLEMS THAT ARE
IN THERE WE HAVE TO PREVENT
THOSE THINGS FROM HAPPENING
AGAIN SO I STAND. IN SUPPORT OF
OUR MEN AND WOMEN WHO WORK IN
THOSE IN. THOSE FACILITIES. TO
MAKE. THEIR LIVES A LITTLE
BETTER AND THEIR JOBS A LITTLE
EASIER. I REGION I'D FIVE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS WALDRON SEEING
NO OTHER MEMBERS SEEKING
RECOGNITION. MR TANG YOU MAY
CLOSE THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
REALLY APPRECIATE THE ROBUST-
DIALOGUE ON THIS BILL I ALSO
WANT TO GO WITH A NUMBER OF
MEMBERS HAD SAID AS MANY OF YOU
KNOW I'VE SPENT A SIGNIFICANT
AMOUNT OF MY TIME. AS BUDGET
CHAIR TO REALLY FOCUS ON THE
REFORMING OF OUR CORRECTIONS
DEPARTMENT IN OUR CORRECTIONAL
FACILITIES I HAVE TO SAY THAT
THIS ORGANIZATION HAS BEEN A
PARTNER AND AS WE HAVE BEEN
WORKING ON THAT THEY ARE
ABSOLUTELY A PIECE OF THE
PUZZLE AS WE HAVE TRIED TO
MAKE. THE ENVIRONMENT BETTER
NOT JUST FOR THE INMATES BUT
ALSO FOR THE OFFICERS FOR THE
DOCTORS FOR ALL THE MENTAL
HEALTH PROFESSIONALS WHO ARE IN
THESE FACILITIES WORKING EVERY
SINGLE DAY THEY'VE ABSOLUTELY
BEEN PART OF THE SOLUTION.
REALLY WOULD URGE ALL OF US TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL AGAIN THIS
BILL IS NO DIFFERENT THAN THE
AND WILL YOU BILL THAT WE TOOK
OFF ON MONDAY WHICH IS FOR
MAKING SURE THAT THESE OFFICERS%
ARE MADE WHOLE AND PLUS THERE
WAS A PRE AGREED UPON- SALARY
NEGOTIATION WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION PRIOR. TO COPE
WITH THAT THIS- AND- YOU TAKES
INTO ACCOUNT SO WITHOUT RESPECT
RESTAURANT. AND WITH THAT
CRITICAL OF THE ROLE. ALL
MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE TO VOTE
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A.
BURKE WELL CLOSE ROLL TIDE OUT
I SEVENTY NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES WITHOUT OBJECTION
IMMEDIATE TRANSMETAL TO THE
SENATE. THIS IS WITHOUT
REFERENCE TO FILE SENATE BILL
ONE FIFTY ONE WITHOUT REFERENCE
TO FILE SENATE BILL ONE FIVE
ONE. CORPORATE SENATE BILL ONE
FIFTY ONE BY THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON BUDGET AND FISCAL
REVIEW AN ACT RELATING TO
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT MAKING
APPROPRIATION OF FOUR TO TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY BE RELATED
TO THE BUDGET MISTER CAN YOU
MAKE IT OPEN I THINK HE WAS A
SPEAKER AT THIS SB ONE FIFTY
ONE IS ON ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
TRAILER BILL THE BILL IS
FOCUSED ON MAKING SURE THAT WE
ARE GIVING ASSISTANCE TO MANY
OF OUR SMALL BUSINESSES THAT
HAVE BEEN HEAVILY HEAVILY
IMPACTED DURING THIS LAST YEAR
ESPECIALLY IN PARTICULAR SMALL
BUSINESSES THAT HAVE STILL YET
TO OPEN- WE'RE PROUD TO HAVE
THE CALIFORNIA VENUES GRANT
PROGRAM WHICH IS REALLY. OF
ABLE TO PROVIDE GRANTS TO
INDEPENDENT THEN USED TO HAVE-
TO MANY MANY EVEN TODAY HAVE
STAYED ON THE HOPE ON OPENED-
THIS ALSO ESTABLISHES THE
CALIFORNIA NONPROFIT PERFORMING
ARTS GRANT PROGRAM AS WELL AS
THE CALIFORNIA MICHAEL BUSINESS
COVERED NINETEEN RELIEF GRANT
PROGRAM IT ALSO ESTABLISHES THE
CALIFORNIA DREAM FROM WHICH A
THIRTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS TO
INCENTIVIZE SMALL BUSINESSES TO
GET ENTREPRENEURSHIP TRAINING I
WITHOUT A RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AYE VOTE ON. SB ONE FIFTY ONE.
THANK YOU MISTER TAKE MR FONG.
I THINK IT WAS JUST BIGGER ARE
THESE INCENTIVES ARE IMPORTANT
START TO HELP OUR SMALL
BUSINESSES THE KHALKHIN PETE'S
GRANT PROGRAM IN CONJUNCTION
WITH THE KALKA PETE'S TAX
CREDIT WILL GIVE BUSINESSES THE
FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE THEY NEED
TO BE HIGHER REINVEST AND
REBUILD. THIS BILL ALSO CREATES
THE VENUE'S GRANT PROGRAM WHICH
IS AN INDUSTRY THAT WOULD NOT
OTHERWISE BE ABLE TO RECEIVE
REALLY FUNDING. LIVE EVENTS
HAVE BEEN CANCELED AND VENUES
HAVE BEEN COMPLETELY SHUT DOWN
DURING THE PANDEMIC SO THIS
BILL TAKES IT ANOTHER STEP
FORWARD TOWARDS RETURNING TO
NORMAL I REGION IVA. DAMOS FONG
SEE NO OTHER MEMBERS SEEKING
RECOGNITION ON THE ITEM. CLICK
LIBERAL. ALL MEMBERS VOTE. IS
THERE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF ALL ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF A. CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ALL CHAT ABOUT I.
SEVENTY FOUR NO ZERO WITHOUT
OBJECTION IMMEDIATE TRANSMITTAL
TO THE SENATE. THIS IS WITHOUT
REFERENCE TO FILE SENATE BILL
ONE FIFTY SEVEN. SENATE BILL
ONE FIVE SEVEN CORKERY SENATE
BILL ONE FIFTY SEVEN BY THE
SENATE COMMITTEE ON BUDGET AND
FISCAL REVIEW AN ACT RELATING
TO LAW ENFORCEMENT MAKING A
PROGRAMS IN THERE FOR A
PRIVILEGE TO THE BUDGET
SIGNIFICANTLY. MISTER K. I
THANK YOU THIS BILL ADDRESSES.
THE RECENT AUDIT FINDINGS THAT
THE CALIFORNIA DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION. MISUSED
STATE FUNDS IN REGARDS TO
SAFEGUARDING THE PROSECUTION.
OF ENVIRONMENTAL CRIMES
ELIMINATES THE ENVIRONMENTAL
CIRCUIT PROSECUTOR PRO PROJECT.
AND ESTABLISHES THE
ENVIRONMENTAL PROSECUTOR GRANT
PROGRAM. IT MOVES THE AUTHORITY
FROM THE DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S
ASSOCIATION TO THE CALIFORNIA.
ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION AGENCY
THE CALIPERS FOR THE COST OF
PROSECUTORS INVESTIGATORS AND
RESEARCH ATTORNEYS FOR
PROSECUTING.THESE CRIMES IT
ALSO SHIFTS THE AUTHORIZATION
OF FUNDS UNDER THE
ENVIRONMENTAL ENFORCEMENT
TRAINING AFTER TWO THOUSAND TWO
AWAY. FROM THE CALIFORNIA
DISTRICT ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION
INSTEAD ALLOCATES FUNDING TO
QUALIFY. GRANTEES TO DEVELOP
AND IMPLEMENT SPECIFIED
EDUCATION TRAINING PROGRAMS IT
ALSO PROHIBITS. THE AWARDING OF
A GRANT OR THE CREATION OF NEW
CONTRACTS UNDER THE CALIFORNIA
DISTRICT ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION.
FOR THE SPECIFIED PROGRAMS.
WITHOUT ROB MEMBERS ARE
RESPECTFULLY THAT'S RIDE VOTE
FOR SB ONE FIVE SEVEN. THANK
WHICH TEAM MR FONG. I THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER. THE ACTIONS OF
THE CALIFORNIA DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION WARRANTS
MORE OVERSIGHT MORE
TRANSPARENCY AND PERHAPS A
REVIEW OF BOOKKEEPING WHICH IS
NECESSARY THE SOLUTION HOWEVER
IS NOT THE STRIP THE
ASSOCIATION OF FUNDING
COMPROMISING OUR DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S ABILITY TO PROTECT
THE PUBLIC RESPONSE TO THE
FINDINGS ARE LOCAL DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS HAVE AGREED TO
INCREASE THEIR DUES TO PAY BACK
THE MISAPPROPRIATED FUNDS. AND
THEY WILL BE SUBJECT TO FURTHER
AUDIT AND SCRUTINY BUT IF THIS
SOLUTION IS APPLIED TO STATE
AGENCIES DEBBIE VERY FEW STATE
AGENCIES LEFT SO AND FOR THAT
REASON I CANNOT SUPPORT THIS
BILL TODAY. I THINK IT WAS FONG
SEE NO OTHER MEMBERS SEEKING
RECOGNITION. CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE MEMBERS. IT IS OUT OF
OUT OF MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A.
WELL CLOSE YOUR ROLL TIDE ABOUT
I. SIXTY EIGHT. NO ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES WITHOUT
OBJECTION MEDIA TRANSMITTAL TO
THE SENATE. MISTER CHOW YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR PROCEDURAL
MOTION THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER SPEAKER I MOVE TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE IS SIXTY
THREE AND SEVENTY SEVEN TO
ALLOW ASSEMBLYMEMBER ATTAIN TO
TAKE UP THE FOLLOWING BILLS
WITHOUT REFERENCE TO FILE FOR
THE PURPOSE OF CONCURRENCE AND
SENATE AMENDMENTS. AB. ONE
FORTY ONE EIGHTY ONE FORTY
THREE AND AB ONE FORTY FIVE. MR
FLOOR FOR PURPOSE SIR WE WILL
HOLD YOU KNOW SKILLS ENOUGH FOR
LOCAL THIS YEAR FLORA IS
WITHHOLDING MISTER CHAO MOVES
AND MISTER GIBSON SECONDS ON
THE RULES SUSPENSION. CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. MR CHAO'S
ASKING FOR AN AYE VOTE TO MR
FLOOR I KNOW THIS IS A
PROCEDURAL VOTE BEFORE THE
ASSEMBLY. MISTER CHAZ ASKING
FOR AN AYE VOTE. MISTER FLORES
ASKING FOR NOVA. CLARK WELL.
CLOSE RALPH THAILAND ICT FIVE
KNOWS NINETEEN THE RULES ARE
SUSPENDED.
THIS IS WITHOUT
REFERENCE TO FILE. ASSEMBLY
BILL ONE THIRTY FOUR MR TANG
ASSEMBLY BILL. ONE THIRTY FOUR.
AB ONE THREE FOUR WITHOUT
REFERENCE TO FILE. FOR THE
PURPOSE OF CONCURRENCE AND
SENATE AMENDMENTS THE CORPORATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL ONE THIRTY FOR BY
THE COMMITTEE ON BUDGET AND
AFTER LIVING A MENTAL HEALTH
AND MAKING AN APPROPRIATION
THEREFORE TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY BUT RELATED TO THE
BUDGET. MISTER KING. I THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER AB ONE
THIRTY FOURS ARE MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES ACT TRAILER BILL. THE
TRAILER BILL EXTENSIVE
FLEXIBILITIES FOR COUNTIES. AS
THEY USE THEIR MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES ACT OR PROP SIXTY
THREE FUNDS. LAST YEAR'S BUDGET
APPROVED OF THIS FLEXIBILITY TO
RESPONSE THE PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCY. SPECIFICALLY THE
FLEXIBILITIES ALLOW COUNTY
SUSPEND DOWN THERE PRUDENT
RESERVES WITHOUT ADDITIONAL
STATE APPROVALS CHAU ALLOWS
THEM TO SHARE FUNDS BETWEEN
PROGRAM'S. COMPONENTS AS NEEDED
CONTINUES TO USE THESE PLANS
COMPLAIN UPDATES ALREADY IN
PLACE WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY
ASK RIVAL FOR SB ONE THIRTY
FOUR. THANK YOU MISTER TANK. MR
FONG YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. BUT
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
MEMBERS I RISE IN SUPPORT OF AB
ONE THIRTY FOUR FLEXIBILITY IS
BECOMING THE MOST EFFECTIVE
RESPONSE TO THE MENTAL HEALTH
CHALLENGES FACING OUR SOCIETY.
IS AN EVER CHANGING AN ALL
ENCOMPASSING PENNED EPIDEMIC
THAT HAS REACHED US IN WAYS
THAT WE COULD NEVER HAVE
IMAGINED. WE SHOULD BE
ENCOURAGING YOU IN
COLLABORATIVE WAYS DOUBLES OR
MENTAL HEALTH AND BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH SYSTEMS SIMPLY TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL TODAY I URGE
I ABOUT. THANK YOU MISS FONG.
SIENDO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THE ITEM. CORPORAL DESIRABLE
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS THAT A VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OTHERS ADVENT.
CLICK WELL CLOSE ROW TELL YOU
THAT HIGHS SEVENTY FIVE NO ZERO
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN. WITHOUT REFERENCE THE FILE
THIS IS AB. ONE THIRTY SEVEN AB
ONE THIRTY SEVEN. AND A
CORPORATE. ASSEMBLY BILL ONE
THIRTY SEVEN BY THE COMMITTEE
ON BUDGET AND AFTER LIVING THE
STATE GOVERNMENT MAKE YOU CAN
MARK THE PERFECT APPROPRIATION
OF FOUR SIGNIFICANTLY PRIVILEGE
TO THE BUDGET. MISTER KING YOU
MAKE IT ALL BUT- THANK YOU
MEMBERS ARE AB ONE THIRTY SEVEN
IS OUR GENERAL GOVERNMENT
TRAILER BILL THIS BILL
INCENTIVIZES THE CONSTRUCTION
OF NEW MULTI FAMILY OR SINGLE
FAMILY ALL ELECTRIC OR- ALL
ELECTRIC HOMES ARE ENERGY
STORAGE SYSTEMS. IT ALSO
ESTABLISHES THE FULL
RESTITUTION FUND FOR THOSE WHO
WERE VICTIMS TO FRAUDULENT
SOLAR INSTALLATIONS INCREASES
GRANTS FOR FINANCIAL
EMPOWERMENT EDUCATION FOR AT
RISK POPULATIONS ALSO ADDS
MONEY FOR A GRANT PROGRAM TO
SELL SUPPORT SURVIVORS OF HATE
CRIMES AND THEIR FAMILIES WILL
INVESTING IN ANTI HATE MEASURES
AND HE CRIME PREVENTION. ALSO
ESTABLISHES THE FOUR STORY
INVOLUNTARILY STERILIZATION
COMPENSATION PROGRAM TO PROVIDE
COMPENSATION TO VICTIMS OF PAST
EUGENICS LAWS AND FORCED
STERILIZATION. WITHOUT RESPECT
FOR US RIDE VOTE ON AB ONE
THIRTY SEVEN. THANK YOU MR
CHANG MR FAR. BUT THERE WAS A
BIGGER MEMBERS I AM FORCING THE
RISE IN OPPOSITION AB ONE THREE
SEVEN IN A TIME OF CALIFORNIANS
ARE BOGGED DOWN UNDER BACKWARDS
BUREAUCRATIC REGULATIONS WE
SHOULD BE MAKING THEIR LIVES
EASIER. UNFORTUNATELY THIS BILL
DIVERTS RESOURCES FROM HELPING
US RECOVER. THE MEDIAN PRICE OF
A SINGLE FAMILY HOME IS NO
LONGER TENABLE FOR MOST HAVE
CALIFORNIANS. THIS MEASURE WILL
INCREASE THE COST OF
CONSTRUCTION AND UTILITIES AND
FURTHER SHRINK THE NUMBER OF
FOLKS WHO CAN AFFORD TO BUY A
HOME. ACCORDING TO A JULY
TWENTY TWENTY REPORT BY THE
FOUNDATION FOR RESEARCH ON
EQUAL OPPORTUNITY QUOTE
RESTRICTIONS ON NATURAL GAS USE
RESULT. IN EVEN LARGER ENERGY
BILLS FOR CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS
AND FURTHER EXACERBATE THE
STATE'S POVERTY PROBLEM.
BANNING THE USE OF NATURAL GAS
IMPOSED A REGRESSIVE ENERGY TAX
ON LOW AND MIDDLE INCOME
CONSUMERS. PROHIBITING THE
DIRECT CONSUMPTION OF NATURAL
GAS IN FURNACES STOVES CLOTHES
DRYERS AND WATER HEATERS. FOR
JUST CONSUMERS TO BUY
ELECTRICITY WHICH IN CALIFORNIA
IS FOUR TIMES AS EXPENSIVE AS
NATURAL GAS ON AN ENERGY
EQUIVALENT BASIS AND QUOTE. WE
NEED TO BE DIVERSIFYING OUR
ENERGY PORTFOLIO BUT PICKING
WINNERS AND LOSERS IN AND THE
MARKET WILL ONLY CONTINUE TO
DRIVE UP OUR COST OF LIVING.
OUR PRIORITY SHOULD BE MAKING
CALIFORNIA MORE AFFORDABLE OR
LIVABLE AND MORE WELCOMING FOR
THE HARD WORKING FAMILIES AND
BUSINESSES THEY CALL THIS GREAT
STATE OUR HOME. MEMBERS
AVERAGING ABOUT. I SEE NO OTHER
MEMBERS SEEKING RECOGNITION. ON
THE BUDGET BILL THIS BUDGET
BILL. SEVERAL OTHER OF. ESERVER
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL. CLOSE ROLL TIDE
ABOUT HIGHS FIFTY FIVE NEWS
THIRTEEN THE SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN. MEMBERS
WITHOUT REFERENCE THE FILE THIS
IS ASSEMBLY BILL ONE THIRTY
EIGHT AB ONE THREE EIGHT.
CORPORATE. ASSEMBLY BILL ONE
THIRTY EIGHT BY THE COMMITTEE
ON BUDGET AND ACALANES
EMPLOYMENT MAKING
APPROPRIATION- FORTS TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY BROUGHT
PEOPLE INTO THE BUDGET. MISTER
TECH- THIS IS OUR LABOR TRAILER
BILL APPROPRIATES FUNDS FOR
RETIREE HEALTH CARE AND OTHER
BENEFITS. IT ALSO ESTABLISHES
THE GARMENT WORKER WAGE CLAIM
PILOT PROGRAM DIFFERENT WAGE
FRAUD. IT ALSO MAKES A NUMBER
OF CHANGES TO EDT AND IN
PARTICULAR INCREASED LANGUAGE
ACCESS AND- PROVIDES CONSUMERS
A DIRECT DEPOSIT OPTION. IT
ALSO OFGEM AUGMENTS THE SCHOOL
EMPLOYEE FUND IN AUGUST
CONTRIBUTION TO IT AND
ADDITIONALLY THE BILL ALSO
EXTENDS A PAID FAMILY LEAVE
BENEFITS TO KEEP THEM FROM
BEING PRODUCED I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AYE VOTE ON AB ONE
THIRTY IT. THANK YOU MISTER
TANK MR FONG. I THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER WE ALL KNOW THE
EDT IS BROKEN NEARLY A YEAR AND
A HALF LATER THERE ARE STILL
OVER A MILLION CALIFORNIANS WHO
ARE STUCK. IN THEIR COMPUTER
SYSTEM THE EDT IS IN DESPERATE
NEED OF STRUCTURE REFORMS AS
CALIFORNIANS DIG THEMSELVES OUT
OF UNEMPLOYMENT WITH A
SEAMLESSLY ANALYSTS A BACKLOG
OF CLAIMS THIS BILL DOES TAKE A
FEW NECESSARY STEPS TO MAKE
IMPROVEMENTS AT EDT. WHICH I
APPLIED. BUT IN THIS BILL THERE
ARE ADDITIONAL OKAY THAT THERE
ARE ADDITIONAL QUESTIONABLE
REGULATIONS THAT WILL EXPOSE
ARE ALREADY STRUGGLING
EMPLOYERS TO MORE LAWSUITS. TO
VIEW DO WE WANT TO BE A STATE
THAT ENCOURAGES BUSINESSES TO
GROW TO RETAIN AND CREATE JOBS.
OR DO WE WANT TO BE KNOWN AS A
STATE WHERE CALIFORNIANS WANT
TO FLEE. OUR BUSINESS COMMUNITY
IS STILL RECOVERING FROM
DISASTERS OF THE PAST YEAR IN
AND INSTEAD OF ENCOURAGING
COMPLIANCE. THIS BILL
ENCOURAGES LITIGATION IN A ONE
SIDED APPROACH TO BACK THEM UP
AGAINST THE WALL EVEN MORE
MEMBERS AVERAGING ABOUT. THANK
YOU MR FONG MISTER Q. YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER COLLEAGUES I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF SB ONE THIRTY EIGHT.
EVERYONE OF US IS ALL TOO
FAMILIAR WITH THE CHALLENGES
AROUND EIGHTY AND I JUST WANT
TO. RECOGNIZE THE CHAIR OF
BUDGETS OF FOUR AND OUR
COLLEAGUES WE HELD MANY
OVERSIGHT HEARINGS DURING THIS
PANDEMIC. TO DIVE INTO EDT
FAILURES AND TO FIGURE OUT
MEANINGFUL SOLUTIONS TO PUSH
THROUGH THIS YEAR'S BUDGET.
WELL THIS TRAILER BILL WON'T
SOLVE ALL OF EDIE'S PROBLEMS IT
WILL TAKE SOME SIGNIFICANT
STEPS TO ENSURE. THAT WE WILL
BE FACING SOME OF THE MOST
DIFFICULT CHALLENGES THAT WE'VE
SEEN OVER THE PAST FIFTEEN
MONTHS. THIS BILL PROVIDES
FUNDING AND GUIDELINES TO
PROPEL EASY. TO BEGIN PROVIDING
MEANINGFUL LANGUAGE ACCESS FOR
OUR LIMITED ENGLISH PROFICIENT
CONSTITUENTS. BREAKING DOWN
ACCESS BARRIERS FOR MILLIONS OF
CALIFORNIANS. GIVEN THE
CHALLENGES WITH BANK OF AMERICA
THIS BILL REQUIRES EDT TO
PROVIDE ALL BENEFITS THROUGH
DIRECT DEPOSIT. REDUCING FRAUD
AND SPEEDING UP ACCESS. THIS
BILL ALSO REQUIRES EDT TO
CREATE AND SUBMIT A FRAUD
PREVENTION PLAN TO THE
LEGISLATURE. AS I MENTIONED
THERE IS FAR MORE THAN NEEDS TO
BE DONE AND I KNOW MANY OF US
IN THIS BODY ARE MOVING FOR
OTHER BILLS. TO PUSH FOR MORE
REFORM BUT THIS BILL DOES
REPRESENT A CRUCIAL FIRST STEP
AND I WANT TO THANK OUR BUDGET
SHARE. OUR SUB FOR CHAIR
COMMITTEE STAFF WITH WORKING
WITH THE ADMINISTRATION FOR
THEIR TIRELESS WORK IN
PARTNERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE AND
WITHOUT A RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER
Q. THANK YOU MEMBERS SONORA THE
MEMBERS SEEKING RECOGNITION ON
THE ITEM. CARCLUB THE ROLE. ALL
MEMBERS OF. THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A.
ALL MEMBERS OF. THE DESIRE TO
VOTE. THE CLERK WELL CLOSER
ROLE COUNTED OUT HIGHS FIFTY
SEVEN KNOWS THIRTEEN SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
THIS IS WITHOUT REFERENCE THE
FILE ASSEMBLY BILL. ONE FORTY
ONE AB. ONE FORTY ONE. THE
CLERK WILL READ. ASSEMBLY BILL
ONE FORTY ONE BY THE COMMITTEE
ON BUDGET AND ACT RELATING TO
CANNABIS AND MAKING
APPROPRIATION THEREFORE TO TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY BILL RELATED
TO THE BUDGET. MISTER CHANG YOU
MAY OPEN. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER SPEAKER AB ONE FORTY ONE
IS OUR CANNABIS TRAILER BILL
THIS BILL TAKES A MAJOR STEP TO
MOVING CANNABIS FOLKS I
CANNABIS BUSINESSES OUT OF THE
pTHE WORLD. THE BILL
CONSOLIDATES THREE AGENCIES
INTO ONE AGENCY CREATED THE NEW
DEPARTMENT OF CANNABIS CONTROL
UNDER THE BUSINESS CONSUMER
SERVICES OF HOUSING AGENCY- IN
AB ONE FORTY ONE ALSO INCLUDES
NUMBER PROVISIONS MEANT TO
ENSURE HEALTH AND SAFETY
STANDARDS ARE APPLIED EQUALLY
ACROSS THE BOARD. THE BILL ALSO
EXTENDS THE PERIOD FOR
PROVISIONAL LICENCES CURRENTLY
OVER 80% OF CANNABIS LICENSES
ARE PROVISIONAL AND ALSO
APPROPRIATE A HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS TO SUPPORT LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS IN GETTING
CANNABIS LICENSES INTO BEING
FULLY LICENSED. THE BILL ALSO
CONTAINS IMPLEMENTATION
LANGUAGE CAREFULLY BALANCES THE
CONCERNS OF INDUSTRY AND
ENVIRONMENTAL COMMUNITY RIGHT
GROUP CRITICAL FLEXIBILITY BUT
ENOUGH BENCHMARKS TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE ARE MAKING PROGRESS I
REPRESENTS A WORK IN PROGRESS
WE ARE CURRENTLY CONTINUE TO
WORK ON ANOTHER BILL WHICH WILL
HAVE THE FOLLOWING ELEMENTS.
FOR SUBSEQUENT RENEWALS AFTER
JULY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY
THREE CLARIFICATION THAT
DEMONSTRATION OF SEQUEL
COMPLIANCE INCLUDES A CHECKLIST
TO IDENTIFY ENVIRONMENTAL
IMPACTS AS EXPRESSLY AUTHORIZED
BY SPECIFICALLY GARMENTS. ARE
RECOMMENDED BY CAL CANNABIS.
CLARIFIES THAT IF A LEAD AGENT
IS IN COMPLIANCE WITH SEEK
WHERE THEY ARE NOT SUBJECT TO
COMPLY WITH SEQUEL BENCHMARKS
IN THIS BILL. CLARIFIES THAT
THE LEGISLATURE CONTENT WITH
THAT NO ADDITIONAL EXEMPTIONS
FROM SECRET SHALL BE ADOPTED
WITH RESPECT TO LICENSES UNDER
THIS PROVISION. THAT'S WHAT IS
LEGISLATIVE ATTEMPT THE FUNDS
APPROACH THE FUNDS APPROPRIATED
IN. THE BUDGET ACT OF TWENTY
TWENTY ONE TO REPUBLIC DEPLOYED
TO ALLOW LOCAL JURISDICTIONS TO
MEET THE DEADLINES IN THE FACT.
IT ALSO WILL DELAY THE DEADLINE
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF FOOD AND
AGRICULTURE IN ESTABLISHING A
PROCESS FOR LICENSED
CULTIVATORS TO ESTABLISH
APPELLATIONS OF ORIGIN. TWO
JULY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY TWO
OUT WE ALSO NEED TO CONTINUE TO
DO MORE WITH GREATER WORK
AROUND SOCIAL EQUITY WE GOT
QUITE A BIT OF FEEDBACK ON THAT
BUT CONTINUES TO BE. A POINT OF
DISCUSSION HERE IN SACRAMENTO
WITHOUT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AYE VOTE ON AB ONE FORTY ONE.
THANK YOU MR CHANG MR FONG YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED. BUT THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER. IT IS CERTAINLY
A REMARKABLE DAY IN SACRAMENTO
WHEN WE CONSIDER A BILL THAT
ACTUALLY CONSOLIDATES THE SIZE
OF GOVERNMENT BUT UNFORTUNATELY
THIS BILL IGNORES THE INPUT OF
IMPORTANT STAKEHOLDERS OUR ROLE
HERE IS THE GOVERNOR OPENLY AND
HONESTLY AND OF COURSE TO
LISTEN HERE THE INPUTS OF THOSE
YOU REPRESENT WITH SO MUCH
STILL TO BE WORKED OUT. I
CANNOT SUPPORT THIS BILL TODAY.
I THINK I MISSED FONG MR LACKEY.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS THERE
CLEARLY ARE SOME SUPPORTABLE
MEASURES IN THIS PARTICULAR
CONSIDERATION BUT LET ME SPEAK
TO THE POISON PILL FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE MORE SYKORA. THE
DOMINANCE OF THE ILLICIT MARKET
IS FAR MORE DAMAGING TO OUR
ENVIRONMENT THAN ANY SINGLE
REGULATION COULD ACCOMPLISH AND
SUPPORTING OUR ENVIRONMENT. THE
ILLICIT MARKET RIGHT NOW THE
GIRLS ARE BLANKETING THE
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA DESERT
WHERE I LIVE. OVER FIFTEEN
HUNDRED. OF THESE ALYSSA GROVES
ARE POISONING OUR LAND AND
LITERALLY STEALING PRECIOUS
WATER. FROM OUR DESERT. WARM
MORE REGULATORY RESTRICTIONS ON
THE LEGAL GROWERS WRONGLY
STRENGTHEN THE EXTREME
ADVANTAGE A DOMINANCE OF
ILLICIT MARKET SO I CANNOT
SUPPORT THIS. FAMOUS LACKEY DR
QUIRK YOUR RECOGNIZE YES I
RECOGNIZE THE CONCERNS THAT-
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FROM PALMDALE
HAS HOWEVER THE- IT CHAIR
CHIANG AND THE BUDGET COMMITTEE
HAVE SAID THAT THEY'RE GOING TO
OUR RE LOOK AT THE SEQUOIA-
REGULATIONS SO THAT IT WILL NOT
BE THE LARGE BURDEN UPON THE
LEGAL GROWERS AND I THANK THE
COMMITTEE VERY MUCH FOR DOING
THAT. THANK ACT COURT EMAIL
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THE ITEM. CLICK LIBERAL. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE THIS TAKES. FIFTY
FOUR- WELL. CLOSE A ROLL TIDE
ABOUT ICE FIFTY SIX KNOWS
FIFTEEN SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. THIS IS. MEMBERS
WITHOUT REFERENCE TO FILE THIS
IS ASSEMBLY BILL ONE FORTY
THREE AB ONE FOUR THREE. AND
THE COOPERATE. ASSEMBLY BILL
ONE FORTY THREE BY THE
COMMITTEE ON BUDGET AND AFTER
LETTING THE COURTS AND MAKING
AN APPROPRIATION OF FORCE TAKE
AFFECT IMMEDIATELY BILL RELATED
TO THE BUDGET. MISTER TECH
THINK ABOUT SPEAKER AB ONE
FORTY THREE IS IT FOR THE BILL
RELATED TO COURTS THE BILL
EXPANDS THE ABILITY TO PAY
ONLINE ADJUDICATION PROTRACTED
PROGRAM TO SUPPORT THE
REDUCTION OF TRAFFIC RELATED
DEBT AT THE DIRECTION OF THE
COURT FINALIZES THE COUNTY
ALLOCATION SCHEDULE FOR FEES
ELIMINATION THAT WE INCLUDED IN
THE TWENTY TWENTY BUDGET ACT IT
ALSO CONSOLIDATES TO FUNDS
RELATED TO COURT CONSTRUCTION
FUNDS. THE STATE COURT
FACILITIES CONSTRUCTION FUND
AND THE INTERMEDIATE CRITICAL
NEED TO COUNT IT ALSO MAKES
CHANGES TO THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL
DESIGN BUILD PROCUREMENT
PROCESS AS WELL AS TO CREATE
THE COMMITTEE TO REVIEW THE
OPERATIONS INSTRUCTOR ALL OF
THE COMMISSION ON JUDICIAL
PERFORMANCE WITHOUT A
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE
ON AB ONE FOUR THREE. THANK
MISTING MR FONG. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AVOIDING ACCESS
TO JUSTICE IS THE BEDROCK OF
OUR DEMOCRATIC SYSTEM AND ARE
COUNTY COURTS PROVIDE
CALIFORNIANS THE MOST IMMEDIATE
ACCESS TO OUR LEGAL SYSTEM SO
WITH A BACKLOG OF COURT
CONSTRUCTION I'M HOPEFUL THE
DESIGN BUILD IMPLEMENTATION
WILL STREAMLINED IMPORTANT
COURT CONSTRUCTION. HOWEVER I
SEE THIS BILL COMPOUNDING GET
ANOTHER BROKEN SYSTEM BOTH THE
STATE COURT FACILITIES
CONSTRUCTION FUND AND THE
IMMEDIATE AND CRITICAL NEED TO
COUNT ARE ON THE VERGE OF
INSOLVENCY THE SOLUTION THOUGH
IS NOT TO MERGE THEM BUT TO
HELP THEM RE GROW AND BUILD
BACK THEIR FUNDING BRICK BY
BRICK THESE FUNDS CANNOT
SUPPORT THEMSELVES AND WE ARE
MERELY KICKING THE CAN DOWN THE
ROAD. COUNTIES HAVE ALSO
SUFFERED A SIGNIFICANT LOSS OF
REVENUE AFTER THE LEGISLATURE
ABOLISHED DOZENS OF FINES AND
FEES COUNTY'S RELIED ON IN THIS
BILL IMPOSES A NEW FORMULA THAT
LIKELY WILL LEAD TO COUNTIES
LOSING RESOURCES AND BEING
DENIED BACK BUT REVENUES THE
ADMINISTRATION GUARANTEED. I
URGE IN ABOUT. SEEING NO OTHER
MEMBERS SEEKING RECOGNITION.
CLICK LIBERAL MEMBERS. THE
DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF A ALL MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE. YEAH.
CLARK WELL CLOSER ROLE CALVET
EYES FIFTY FIVE KNOWS ELEVEN
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN THIS IS WITHOUT REFERENCE TO
FILE ASSEMBLY BILL. ONE FORTY
FIVE ONE FOUR FIVE. COOKERY
ASSEMBLY BILL ONE FORTY FIVE BY
THE COMMITTEE ON BUDGET AND I
RELATING TO PUBLIC SAFETY
MAKING A PROBATIONER FOR TO
TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY PAYER
RELATED TO THE BUDGET MISTER K.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AB ONE
FORTY FIVE IS OUR PUBLIC SAFETY
TRAILER BILL FIRST THAT
AUTHORIZES AGENTS OF THE BOARD
OF STATE AND COMMUNITY
CORRECTIONS TO ENTER LOCAL
CORRECTIONAL FACILITIES WITHOUT
NOTICE. THIS OPERATIONALIZED AS
THE CLOSURE OF THE DVI FACILITY
AT OUR FIRST- PRISON CLOSURE
THAT WAS ANNOUNCED BY GOVERNOR
NEWSOM PROHIBIT THE TRANSFER
CERTAIN INCARCERATED PEOPLE TO
COMMUNITY CORRECTIONAL
FACILITIES AND AUTHORIZES THE
CONTRACTS FOR COUNTIES FOR THE
USE OF THE PINE GROVE YOUTH
CONCERTS CONSERVATION CAMP A
JUSTICE SB SIX SEVEN EIGHT
FORMULA FOR WHEN YOU'RE DUE TO
PANDEMIC IMPACTS PROVIDES THE
EQUITABLE RETROACTIVE
EXPUNGEMENT RELIEF FOR
INDIVIDUALS WHO CURRENTLY HAVE
ACCESS TO THIS BELIEF
PROSPECTIVELY AS OF JANUARY
FIRST TWENTY TWENTY ONE. IF
IT'S NOT WHICH IS A
COLLABORATIVE COUNTY RECESSING
PILOT LED BY PROSECUTORS AND
NINE DIVERSE COUNTIES INCLUDING
YELLOW WITH ANGELES MERCED AND
HUMBLE IT ALSO FUNDS PUBLIC
DEFENDER OFFICES TO WORK ON
RECENT THING AS WELL THE MIX
TEXEL TECHNICAL ADJUSTMENTS TO
THE CDC OURS CARE PROGRAM
MISJUDGMENTS TO THE TRAINING
STANDARDS FOR CORRECTIONAL
PEACE OFFICER CADETS IT ALSO
EXPANDS THE NUMBER OF THE BOARD
OF PAROLE COMMISSIONERS FROM
SEVENTEEN TO TWENTY ONE AND
ALSO ENHANCES THE EXPERTISE AND
DIVERSITY OF THAT POOR. WITHOUT
A RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE.
VOTE ON AB ONE FORTY FIVE. THEY
ARE STAYING FONG. I THANK YOU
SPEAKER NO DOUBT OUR PROBATION
A CORRECTIONAL OFFICERS DO
PHENOMENAL WORK IN SIR IN THEIR
SERVING THEIR CLIENTS AND
PROTECTING THE PUBLIC SO I'M
PLEASED TO SEE POLICIES PUT
FORTH THAT RECOGNIZE OUR
COMMITMENT TO PUBLIC SAFETY BUT
IS TROUBLING TO SEE THE
CONTINUED EFFORTS BY SACRAMENTO
TO MAKE THAT THAT THAT THAT
THEY CAN DO TO MAKE TO CLOSED
PRISONS AND DESTABILIZE OUR
PUBLIC SAFETY SYSTEM. THIS BILL
REPEALS CCAR'S ABILITY TO
OPERATE VOCATIONAL INSTITUTE
THAT WOULD FURTHER COMPROMISE
OUR PRISON KEEP KEEP
CAPABILITIES THIS BILL ALSO IS
DEEPLY PROBLEMATIC IN ITS
APPROACH IT REQUIRES
RETROACTIVE EXPUNGEMENT ARREST
RECORDS WITHOUT A CLEAR
DEMONSTRATION OF A PERSON'S
RENEWED DESIRE TO CHANGE AND BE
A PRODUCTIVE CITIZEN IT IS THE
DUTY AND RESPONSIBILITIES OF
THIS BODY TO MAKE POLICIES THAT
KEEP OUR COMMUNITY SAFE AND
SUPPORT THOSE THAT KEEP US
SAFE. I CANNOT SUPPORT THIS
BILL TODAY. I THINK IT WAS
FONG. SENIOR DISCUSSION DEBATE
ON THE ITEM. CLICK LIBERAL
MEMBERS. IT IS AT A VOTE OF ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A. ALL
MEMBERS OF. THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL. CLOSE ROLL TIDE
ABOUT HIGHS FIFTY ONE NO SIX
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN. MISTER CHECK OUT YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR PROCEDURAL
MOTION THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER SPEAKER I MOVE TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE SIXTY
THREE AND SEVENTY SEVEN TO
ALLOW ASSEMBLY MEMBER TEAM TO
TAKE UP THE FOLLOWING BILLS
WITHOUT REFERENCE TO FILE FOR
THE PURPOSE OF CONCURRENCE IN
SENATE AMENDMENTS. AB ONE
THIRTY SIX AB ONE FORTY NINE
AND AB ONE FIFTY. MISTER
FLORIDA WE WERE HOLDING HANDS
CONSERVE NATURAL CALL VOTE
MISTER FLORA IS WITHHOLDING
UNANIMOUS CONSENT MISTER CHOW
MOVES A MISTER GIBSON SECONDS
ON THE RULES SUSPENSION CLERK
IN THE ROLE. CHALICE ASKING FOR
AN AYE VOTE MISTER FLORES
ASKING FOR NOVA MEMBERS THIS IS
A PROCEDURAL VOTE THIS IS
PROCEDURAL. MR SHOWERS ASKING
FOR AN AYE VOTE. MISTER FLORIDA
NOBODY. WELL CLOSER ROLE HIGHS
FIFTY THREE KNOWS NINETEEN THE
RULES ARE SUSPENDED. WITHOUT
REFERENCE THE FILE. THIS IS
ASSEMBLY BILL. ONE THIRTY SIX.
AB ONE THREE SIX CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL ONE THIRTY SIX BY
THE COMMITTEE ON BUDGET AND
AFTER LEADING TO DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES AND MAKING
APPROPRIATION THEREFORE TO TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY PAYER
RELATED TO THE BUDGET. MISTER
KING I THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
AB ONE THIRTY SIX IS OUR
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES TRAILER
BILL IN THIS. I TRAILER BILL IS
ABSOLUTELY A DIRECT RESULT OF
THE ADVOCACY FROM. SO MANY ON
THIS FLOOR AT THE HISTORIC
MOMENT IN HISTORIC TRAILER BILL
FOR INDIVIDUALS AND FAMILY
MEMBERS WITH INTELLECTUAL AND
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES. IN
TWENTY SIXTEEN THIS VERY
LEGISLATURE. ASK FOR A RATE
STUDY TO BE COMPLETED IN THREE
YEARS LATER IN TWENTY NINETEEN
WE RECEIVED THE RESULTS. OF THE
STUDY IN THAT RESULTS SHOWED A
STAGGERING OVER ONE BILLION
DOLLAR DEFICIT. THE
SHORTCOMINGS OF WHAT WE NEED TO
MAKE UP IN TERMS OF RATES. WELL
TODAY WE ARE TAKING ONE HUGE
LEAP. TO IMPLEMENTING THIS RATE
STUDY OVER THE NEXT FIVE YEARS
WE WILL ALSO INCORPORATE A
QUALITY INCENTIVE PROGRAM TO
ENSURE THE SERVICES AND
SUPPORTS. ARE THERE TO MEET THE
NEEDS OF THE PEOPLE IN THE
FAMILIES THEY SERVE. IN
ADDITION THIS BILL ALSO
RESTORES SOCIAL AND RECREATION
CAMP SERVICES A CUT THAT WAS
MADE IN THE LAST GREAT
RECESSION. IT INCLUDES EXPANDED
IMPLICIT IMPLICIT EXCUSE ME
IMPLICIT BIAS TRAINING FOR ALL
REGIONAL CENTERS. FOSTER THE
LANGUAGE ACCESS AND CULTURAL
COMPETENCY EFFORT TO IMPROVE
ACCESS. ALSO PROVIDES FOR
REMOTE SERVICES AND
FLEXIBILITIES FOR CONTINUE TO
CONTINUE POST PANDEMIC. AS WELL
AS ELIMINATE THE STATUTORY
SUSPENSIONS FOR THE D. D.
PROGRAM. WITHOUT A RESPECT FOR
US FOR A. VOTE FOR AB ONE
THIRTY SIX. MISTER FONG
RECOGNIZED. I THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER TODAY IS TRULY A
MOMENTOUS DAY FOR
DEVELOPMENTALLY DISABLED
COMMUNITY FOR WHOM WE HAVE ALL
ADVOCATED FOR YEARS. I LIKE TO
TAKE A MOMENT TO THANK THE
DEDICATION OF MY COLLEAGUES
FROM FAIRFIELD PALMDALE SAN
MATTEO ESCONDIDO BY SALIH AND
FRESNO. FOR THEIR CONTINUOUS
ADVOCACY TO SUPPORT THE DDS
RIGHT STUDY AND THE LONG
AWAITED RATE INCREASE FOR
SERVICE PROVIDERS. FOR FAR TOO
LONG CALIFORNIANS WITH
INTELLECTUAL AND
DEVELOPMENTALLY DISABLED
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES HAVE
BEEN UNSERVED THIS BILL
REMEDIES THAT. WE CAN FINALLY
HAVE A FAILED THE MANY PROMISES
MADE OVER THE YEARS AND HONOR
OUR COMMITMENTS TO THIS GLOBAL
COMMUNITY I STRONGLY URGE
NIVEAU. THANK YOU MR FONG
MISTER MATHIS YOUR RECOGNIZE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS I RISE IN STRONG
SUPPORT. OF AB ONE THIRTY SIX
MEMBERS YOU ALL KNOW I'M A
FATHER OF CHILDREN WITH
DISABILITIES. IN THE RELIEF
THAT THIS IS GOING TO BRING TO
SO MANY FAMILIES. IT IS TRULY
GOING TO BE REMARKABLE WHAT
THIS DOES FOR OUR DISABLED
COMMUNITY. THE IMPLEMENT TATIAN.
OF THESE RECOMMENDATIONS FROM
THIS RATE STUDY THIS RATE STUDY
THAT MANY OF MY COLLEAGUES FROM
BUDGET SUB ONE. HAVE BEEN
WORKING ON. FRANKLY OVER THE
LAST SEVEN YEARS. FIGHTING DAY
IN AND DAY OUT. IN COMMITTEE
HEARINGS OUT ON THE STREETS
BACK IN THE COMMUNITIES TO
ENSURE THAT THIS ACTION GETS
DONE THAT THIS COMMUNITY IS
MADE WHOLE. THERE WERE PROMISES
MADE YEARS AND YEARS AGO. IN
PROMISES THAT WERE BROKEN. IN
THIS FINALLY FULFILL THOSE
PROMISES IT MAKES. OUR DISABLED
COMMUNITY WHOLE INTAKES ARE
STEP. IN OUR STAY CLOSER TO
ENSURING THAT COMMITMENT. THE
MEMBERS WE GOT HERE. BECAUSE
OUR STATE GOT COMPLACENT. WE
NEED TO ENSURE THAT WE NEVER DO
THAT AGAIN. WE NEED TO MAKE
SURE THAT. WE PROCEED IN
ENSURING THE HIGHEST QUALITY OF
LIFE POSSIBLE FOR DISABLED
COMMUNITY. MEMBERS I CAN TALK
ON THIS. FRANKLY ALL DAY LONG
BUT I KNOW WE HAVE OTHER
COLLEAGUES THAT I'VE WORKED
JUST AS HARD AS I HAVE THAT
WANT TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
THIS MEMBERS THE I EXPECT TO
SEE EVERYBODY VOTE YES ON THIS.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MUCH
MATHIS DR ARAMBULA YOUR
RECOGNIZE. THANK YOU MR SPEAKER
AND MEMBERS TODAY I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF AB ONE THIRTY SIX
OUR DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES
TRADE BUDGET TRAILER BILL AS
MANY PEOPLE OF REFERENCE THE
TWENTY NINETEEN RATE STUDY
WHICH WAS TO ADDRESS THE
SUSTAINABILITY QUALITY AND
TRANSPARENCY OF THE COMMUNITY
BASED SERVICES FOR INDIVIDUALS
AND R. I. D. D. POPULATIONS.
BUT THAT RATE STUDY IDENTIFIED
OVER ONE BILLION DOLLARS IN
GAPS TO OUR PROVIDERS VERSUS
WHAT WE WERE FUNDING VERSUS
WHAT THEY NEEDED AND I AM PROUD
TO ANNOUNCE THAT THE BUDGET
THAT IS BEFORE US WILL CLOSE
THOSE GAPS IN A PHASED IN
APPROACH BY TWENTY TWENTY THREE
TWENTY TWENTY FOUR. THIS WILL
PROVIDE STABILITY FOR A SYSTEM
THAT HAS BEEN ROCKED IN COBIT
AND HAS BEEN HISTORICALLY
UNDERFUNDED. THESE ACTIONS MEAN
WE WILL FULFILL THE PROMISE OF
THE LAND SHERMAN ACT ON WHICH
SO MANY RELY FOR A SAFE FULL
AND DIGNIFIED LIVES IN OUR
COMMUNITIES. AB ONE THIRTY SIX
ALSO BROADENS THE EARLY START
SERVICES FOR THREE FOUR AND
FIVE YEAR OLDS ALLOWING US TO
ENSURE THAT MORE CHILDREN CAN
SEEK SERVICES. AND HAVE. AND
SEEK SERVICES AT A CRITICAL
POINT IN THEIR DEVELOPMENT.
OTHER NOTABLE INVESTMENTS INTO
OUR DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES
PROGRAMS INCLUDE ENHANCING OUR
SERVICE COORDINATING RATIOS AS
WELL AS RESTORING THE SOCIAL
RECREATION AND CAMP SERVICES.
FOR ITT POPULATION AS WELL AS
PROMOTING LANGUAGE ACCESS AND
CULTURAL COMPETENCY WITHIN OUR
DD SYSTEM. I ALSO WOULD LIKE TO
THANK MY COLLEAGUES FROM
FAIRFIELD FROM PASADENA FROM BY
SALIA AND SAN MATTEO WHO OF ALL
JOINED US IN ADVOCATING TO MAKE
SURE WE CAN PROVIDE RESOURCES.
TO THIS COMMUNITY. I AM HONORED
TO VOTE FOR THIS MEMBERS AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE HERE TODAY. THANK YOU
DOCTOR IN THE LAB MR LACKEY YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED. JUST REAL
QUICKLY I'M VERY VERY PROUD OF
THIS BODY FOR FINALLY STANDING
UP AND DOING THE RIGHT THING.
IN ADDRESSING THIS POPULATION
FAIRLY NO BACK IN NINETEEN
SEVENTY SEVEN. AS WE PASSED THE
LAB FROM AN ACT. THIS IS THE
FIRST TIME. SINCE I'VE BEEN IN
THE LEGISLATURE WHICH IS THIS
MY SEVENTH YEAR WE'VE COME EVEN
CLOSE. TO HONORING LAW THAT WE
SET FOR OURSELVES. FINALLY
WE'RE TRYING TO COMPLY. AND A
VERY VERY VERY THANKFUL AS ARE
MANY OF THE CONSTITUENTS. WILL
BENEFIT FROM THIS. RECOGNITION
IT IS REALLY REALLY REALLY
GOING TO BE IMPACTFUL AND I'M
JUST VERY VERY THANKFUL AND I.
A VERY PROUD AND NOT
EMBARRASSED FOR THE FIRST TIME
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISSION I
CAME IS VALID THERE'S- MEMBERS
I RISE- IN STRONG SUPPORT OF-
WHAT S. S. B. ONE THIRTY SEVEN
AS A FORMER EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
AT AUTISM SPEAKS I'VE BEEN ON
THE FRONT LINES FIGHTING FOR
SPECIAL NEEDS FAMILIES AND
THOSE WITH. DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES FUNDING FOR
SERVICES FIREFIGHTING FOR
THERAPIES THE AVERAGE FAMILY
WITH AN INDIVIDUAL HAS AN
INDIVIDUAL WITH I. D. D. FOR
THAT INDIVIDUAL AND THAT'S IF
THEY HAVE INSURANCE. CHILDREN
INDIVIDUALS HAVING ACCESS TO
THE SERVICES THE TREATMENTS IN
THE THERAPIES THAT NEED THAT
THEY NEED CHANGE LIVES CHANGE
FAMILIES AND IT'S THE RIGHT
THING TO DO SOURCE I STRONGLY
URGE FOR YOUR YOUR SUPPORT ON
THIS MATTER THANK YOU. I THANK
HIS FATHER SAY GIVE ADVERSE. MR
FRAZIER. YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU. WE DID IT. WE DID IT.
WE CURRENT AMOUNT FOR THIS
COMMUNITY. AND FROM THE BOTTOM
OF MY HEART I THANK YOU. MY
COLLEAGUE FROM SAN MATTEO
THERE'S ALWAYS BEEN THERE.
WE'VE ENCOURAGED EACH OTHER.
FROM PASADENA POLY WHO'S ALWAYS
SO THOROUGH ABOUT PROCESS FOR
THIS COMMUNITY. MY SOMEONE
CHAIR. THANK YOU SO VERY MUCH.
A HUGE SHOUT OUT TO OUR BUDGET
CHAIR YESTERDAY. FOR HEARING
LISTENING AND BEING A STRONG
ADVOCATE FOR THIS COMMUNITY.
AND ALSO WITH PERMISSION MR
TANG. I WANT A BIG SHOUT OUT TO
NICOLE VASQUEZ IN THE COMMITTEE.
WHO FIELDED. HER DILIGENCE OR
HARDWORK HER COMPASSION BARNARD
WILL HUGE REASONS THAT THIS WAS.
A BIG FACTOR IN IN THE BUDGET.
MISTER SPEAKER. YOUR AMAZING.
THANK YOU FOR BELIEVING IN.
LET'S NOT BECOME COMPLACENT
THIS IS A PHASED IN OVER FIVE
YEARS. THIS DOESN'T AUGMENT THE
BUDGET FOR THIS COMMUNITY THIS
BRINGS US TO A ZERO SUM GAME.
OF DRACONIAN CUTS OVER MANY
MANY YEARS. THIS IT COMMUNITY
GROWS BY 25% EVERY DECADE. SO
WE HAVE TO FACTOR THAT IN AGAIN
WE ARE THE GUARDIANS FOR THIS
COMMUNITY. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
FOR SUPPORTING THIS COMMUNITY
OF PEOPLE. THANK YOU MISTER
FRAZIER. WITH THAT CAR CLUB THE
ROLE ALL MEMBERS OF. WHAT IS
THAT ABOUT ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE VOTE. ALL MEMBERS OTHERS
ARE TO VOTE.
WELL. CLOSE A ROLL
TIDE ABOUT I SEVENTY FIVE NO
ZERO. SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN.
WITHOUT REFERENCE
THE FILE THIS IS ASSEMBLY BILL
ONE FORTY NINE. AB ONE FOUR
NINE COOKERY ASSEMBLY BILL ONE
FORTY NINE BY THE COMMITTEE ON
BUDGET AND AFTER LEAVING THE
TRANSPORTATION OF MAKING
APPROPRIATION ARE FOR TO TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY BE RELATED
TO THE BUDGET. MISTER CHANG I
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AB ONE
FORTY NINE IS OUR
TRANSPORTATION TRAILER BILL THE
BILL EXTENDS ROAD TEMPORARY
RELIEF FOR TRANSIT AGENCIES
IMPACTED BY COAL THAT NINETEEN
THAT WERE INCLUDED IN THE
TWENTY TWENTY BUDGET ALSO
PROVIDES TEMPORARY RELIEF FOR
CITIES AND COUNTIES WITH
RESPECT TO THEIR LOCAL STREETS
IN ROAD MAINTENANCE OF EFFORTS
IT ALSO ESTABLISHES THE CLEAN
CALIFORNIA LOCAL GRANT PROGRAM
IN THE CLEAN CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIFICATION PROGRAM OF TWENTY
TWENTY ONE TO ALLOCATE GRANTS
TO LOCAL TO CLEAN UP LOCAL
STREETS ROADS. TRIBAL LANDS
PARKS PATHWAYS TRADE CENTERS
ANOTHER UBLIC SPACES IT ALSO
AUTHORIZES A PILOT PROGRAM TO
EVALUATE THE USE OF OPTIONAL
MOBILE OR DIGITAL ALTERNATIVES
TO DRIVER'S LICENSES AND
IDENTIFICATION CARDS WITHOUT A
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR I VOTE FOR
AB ONE FORTY NINE. DANISH
CHAIRMAN FONG. I THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER. LOCAL TRANSIT
SAW AN EXTRAORDINARY DROP IN
RIDERSHIP DURING THE PANDEMIC
THIS BILL SHOWS OUR COMMITMENT
TO REVITALIZE OUR COMMUNITIES
AS WE RE OPEN AND CONTINUE ON
THE ROAD TO ECONOMIC RECOVERY.
IS ALSO ON BOARD TO KEEP OUR
ROADS AND HIGHWAYS CLEAN IS
MEASURED WAS RESOURCES AND TO
REMOVE LITTER AND BEAUTIFY
COMMUNITIES IRISH I'VE UP.
THANK YOU MR FONG. SENIOR
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ADAM
CORPORAL OF THE ROLE. ALL
MEMBERS OF THE DATA VOTE ALL
MEMBERS OTHERS OUT OF A. ALL
MEMBERS OTHERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL. CLOSE ROLL TIDE
ABOUT I. SEVENTY SIX NO ZERO
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN. WITHOUT REFERENCE TO FILE
THIS IS ASSEMBLY BILL ONE FIFTY
A. B. ONE FIVE- CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL ONE FIFTY BY THE
COMMITTEE ON BUDGET AND
ACCOLADE IN THE TAXATION OF
MAKING APPROPRIATION THEREFORE
TO TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY
RELATED TO THE BUDGET. MISTER
CHANG. THANK YOU WOULD SPEAKER
AB ONE FIFTY IS OUR REVENUE
TRAILER BILL. THE BILL EXTENDS
INDEFINITELY. THE SALE AND USE
TAX EXEMPTIONS ON DIAPER AND
MENSTRUAL PRODUCTS. EXTENDS
EXISTING 15% TAX CREDIT FOR
FOODS DONATED TO A FOOD BANK
AND TELL TWENTY TWENTY SIX. IT
ALSO EXTENDS THE STATE HISTORIC
TAX CREDIT FOR REHABILITATION
ON CERTIFIED. HISTORIC
STRUCTURES UNTIL TWENTY TWENTY
SIX. IT ALSO INCREASES
ALLOCATION FOR THE CALIFORNIA
COMPETES TAX CREDIT BY A
HUNDRED AND TEN MILLION DOLLARS
FOR A TOTAL OF TWO HUNDRED
NINETY MILLION DOLLARS IN
TWENTY ONE TWENTY. I TWENTY
TWO- BUDGET YEAR IT ALSO
CREATES A HOMELESSNESS HIRING
TAX CREDIT FOR ELIGIBLE
EMPLOYERS TO HIRE EMPLOYEES.
INCLUDING THOSE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS WITHOUT A
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE
ON AB ONE FIFTY. THANK YOU MR
CHANG MR FONG. BUT THERE WAS A
SPEAKER THE KHALKHIN PETE'S AND
MAIN STREET HIRING TAX CREDITS
OFFER OUR SMALL BUSINESSES THE
ABILITY TO RECOVER REBUILD AND
LEAD US BACK TO A THRIVING
ECONOMY. I WOULD THEY'LL ADD
THAT THERE ARE INDEED IMPORTANT
TAX CREDITS LIKE THE RESEARCH
AND DEVELOPMENT TAX CREDIT. FOR
A VITAL BIOTECHNOLOGY INDUSTRY
THAT WERE TAKEN AWAY LAST YEAR.
THAT I BELIEVE SHOULD BE
BROUGHT BACK AS WELL. BUT THE
SMALL BUSINESSES IN OUR IN OUR
STATE IT'S THEIR INNOVATION AND
PREP AND PERSEVERANCE THAT
SERVE AS THE BACKBONE. TO OUR
REINVIGORATED ECONOMY AND SO WE
THINK OUR SMALL BUSINESSES MORE
THAN WE COULD EVER EXPRESS AN
EMPLOYEE TO SUPPORT SB ONE
FIFTY. THANK YOU MR FONG DR
CHOI. YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK
YOU SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I
RISING SUPPORT OF AB UP ONE
FIFTY. ABOUT THE MORAL MIST-
THIS TO BE DONE. AS A
CALIFORNIA LOOKS TO OPEN BACK
UP IT IS A STILL A VISIBLE THAT
OUR BUSINESS A COMMUNITY.
REMAINS A DECIMATED FROM THE
FIFTEEN MONTH ALL BUT ECONOMIC
RESTRICTIONS ARE AND THE
CLOSURES. TOP RATED DOT NUMBERS
SO SHOW THAT BY CALIFORNIA GAME
THE ONLY. ONE HUNDRED FOUR
THOUSAND JOBS ARE IN MAY. AND
THE ENTIRE LABOR LABOR FORCE SO
CRUEL BY JUST A BOX OF TWELVE
THOUSAND WORKERS. MANY
THOUSANDS ABA OPEN JOBS ARE.
GOING UNFILLED AB ONE FIFTY SIX
ARE TWO INCREASED HIRING.
ENCOURAGED INVESTMENT IN
UNDERSERVED AREAS SO AND THE
PROMOTE. ENTER PROMOTION BUT
THE WELL WHAT THIS BILL OUR
BEFORE ASA DOES NOT DO IS NOT
ROLLED BACK ON A MONSTER
RUSSELL NINE POINT TWO BILLION
DOLLAR TAX INCREASE OF FORCED
ON THE BUSINESS OF COMMUNITY
LAST YEAR. THE TAX INCREASES ON
TOP DID NOT LAST YEAR SO
EMERGENCY MANAGERS ARE NO
LONGER NEEDED. BUSINESS IS OR
SHOULD BE IN A LAW SHOULD BE
ALLOWED. TO IMMEDIATE THE-
UTILIZAR M. O. L. NOT OPERATING
LOSS LOSSES SIR AND A PHONE TO
TEXT CRITICISM TO OFFSET THE
ANY HARM THEY HAVE A CELL
PHONE. AS A RESULT OF THIS UP
AND THEN MAKE. AND THOUGH TO
AND- EMPLOYERS WHO ARE
CONSIDERING LEAVING THE STATE
TO STATE. I HAD THE AMENDMENTS
ARE PREPARED TO- THAT THOUGHT
WOULD PUT THEIR IMMEDIATE AND
THE TO THE INSANITY THAT WAS TO
THE IDEA TO RAISE OUR TAXES SO
DURING THE MISS OF UP AND THEN
MAKE BUT IT IS ON NOT POSSIBLE
AT THIS POINT THE- IF.
CALIFORNIA TRULY WANTS TO
FOSTER INVESTMENT INTO THE
ECONOMY AND ENCOURAGES JOB
CREATION NOW I'M NOT WHICH ARE
WHAT. ALL SHOULD NOT PUNISH
EMPLOYERS SO STICKING TO GET
BACK ON TRACK BUT WITH THE
ONGOING HIGHER TAXES. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU DR CHOI SI NO OTHER
MEMBERS SEEKING RECOGNITION ON
THE ITEM. CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE. DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE RESERVE VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSER ROLE HI THAT
I SEVENTY THREE NO ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS. R. CONCURRED IN.
MEMBERS WE WILL NOW MOVE TO THE
SECOND DAY CONSENT CALENDAR
THERE ARE RESOLUTIONS ON
TODAY'S CONSENT CALENDAR BEFORE
WE VOTE. WE WILL FIRST TAKE UP
THE RESOLUTIONS ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR FOR THE PURPOSE OF
ADDING CO AUTHORS THE CLERK
WILL READ THE RESOLUTIONS ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR. HOUSE
RESOLUTION FIFTY FIVE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BOERNER HORVATH
RELATIVE TO THE FOURTH OF JULY.
SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
TWENTY THREE BY CENTER
ARCHULETA RELATIVE TO NATIONAL
MILITARY APPRECIATION MONTH
SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
TWENTY FIVE BY CENTER HER TADO
RELATIVE TO ADULT EDUCATION.
SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
TWENTY NINE BY CENTER WIENER
AND OTHERS RELATIVE TO
CALIFORNIA HOLOCAUST MEMORIAL
DAY. SENATE CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION THIRTY ONE BY SANTA
NEWMAN RELATIVE TO A RAV
AMERICAN HERITAGE MONTH. SENATE
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION THIRTY
THREE BY CENTER ARCH ALETTA AND
OTHERS RELATIVE TO FOOD ALLERGY
AWARENESS WEEK SENATE
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION FORTY BY
CENTER ALLEN RELATIVE TO ARTS
CULTURE AND CREATIVITY MONTH
SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
FORTY EIGHT BY SENATE MCGUIRE
AND OTHERS. BOTH OF TO
CALIFORNIA GROWN PHARMA ANTHONY
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION FIFTY BY
CENTER- CHAU BOKE AND OTHERS
RELATIVE TO ALZHEIMER'S AND
BRAIN AWARENESS. MONTH AND THE
LONGEST DAY. WE'RE GONNA OPEN
THE ROLE TO ALLOW. ADDRESS
AUTHORS TO THE RESOLUTION FOR
CLUB IN THE ROLE. MEMBERS THIS
IS. TO ADD YOUR NAME AS A CO
AUTHOR. ON THE RESOLUTIONS. CO
AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION THIS
IS FOR CO AUTHORS. A CLERK WELL
CLOSER THERE ARE SEVENTY FIVE
CO AUTHORS ADDED WE'RE NOW
MOVING TO VOTE ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR TO SEND A MEMBER WHICH
REMOVE AN ITEM FROM THE CONSENT
CALENDAR SEEING HEARING NONE.
THE CLERK WILL READ THE SECOND
DAY CONSENT CALENDAR HOUSE
RESOLUTION FIFTY FIVE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BOERNER HORVATH
RELATIVE TO THE FOURTH OF JULY
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
THIS IS THE CONSENT CALENDAR
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
THE CONSENT CALENDAR. CLARK
WELL. CLOSE A ROLL TIDE ABOUT I
SEVENTY FIVE NO ZERO THE
CONSENT CALENDAR IS ADOPTED.
FOR READ THE REMAINING ITEMS ON.
SENATE BILL TWO FIFTY FOUR I
SEVENTY FIVE NO ZERO SENATE
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION TWENTY
THREE I SEVENTY FIVE NO ZERO
SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
TWENTY FIVE FIVE SEVENTY FIVE
NO ZERO SENATE CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION TWENTY NINE I
SEVENTY FIVE NO ZERO SENATE
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION THIRTY
ONE I SEVENTY FIVE NO ZERO
SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
THIRTY THREE I. SEVENTY FIVE NO
ZERO SENATE CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION FORTY FIVE SEVENTY
FIVE NO ZERO SENATE CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION FORTY EIGHT HI
SEVENTY FIVE NO ZERO SENATE
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION FIFTY.
FIVE SEVENTY FIVE NO ZERO
SENATE BILL TWO EIGHTY THREE I
SEVENTY FIVE NO ZERO SENATE
BILL SEVEN EIGHTY EIGHT I
SEVENTY FIVE NO ZERO IN SENATE
BILL ELEVEN WITH URGENCY FIVE
SEVENTY FIVE NO ZERO THE
URGENCY. I SEVENTY FIVE NO ZERO
ON THE MEASURE. MEMBERS.
MEMBERS THE PRIVACY AND
CONSUMER PROTECTION COMMITTEE
WILL BE MEETING UPON A GERMAN
IN ROOM FORTY TWO OH TWO THAT'S
PRIVACY UPON A GERMAN IN FORTY
TWO OH TWO WATER PARKS AND
WILDLIFE COMMITTEE WILL BE
MEETING THIRTY MINUTES AFTER
GERMAN IN THIS CHAMBER THAT'S
WATER PERSON WILDLIFE THIRTY
MINUTES IN THE ASSEMBLY CHAMBER.
THIRTY MINUTES AFTER GERMAN.
MEMBERS ARE MOVING TO
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY WITHOUT
OBJECTION THE QUORUM CALL IS
LIFTED AND WE WILL NOW BE
MOVING TO PREVIOUSLY ANNOUNCED
THE GERMANS TO MEMORY. MEMBERS
PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS OR TAKE
YOUR CONVERSATIONS OFF OF THE
FLOOR.
MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR
SEATS OR TAKE YOUR
CONVERSATIONS OFF OF THE FLOOR
WEIRD ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY.
WHERE THE GERMANS TO MEMORY.
MEMBERS WHERE GERMANS PLEASE
TAKE YOUR CONVERSATIONS OFF OF
THE FLOOR.
OKAY THE FOLLOWING
MEMBERS WERE GRANTED PRIOR
PERMISSION TO SPEAK ON A GERMAN
IN MEMORY. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SALIS YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR GERMAN MEMORY. THANK YOU
MR SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I RISE
TODAY TO JOIN IN THE MEMORY OF
ML DACA SILENT KASSETAS LEONA
RESIDENT OF HAVING ALL A
BELOVED BROTHER. THE ACT THE
OUT OF WEDLOCK GRANDMOTHER AND
GREAT GRANDMOTHER. BORN IMELDA
QUEZADA IS IN HER ANCESTRAL
VILLAGE OF LOS MILAGROS AYE MR
KHAN IN NINETEEN THIRTY SIX TO
AGRARIAN PARENTS SHE HAD A
HAPPY CHILDHOOD SURROUNDED BY
LOVING FAMILY. ANOTHER WOULD GO
ON TO MARRY REBOLLEDO LAY ON
AFTER HE BECAME ABOUT US AT ALL
IN NINETEEN FIFTY SEVEN AND
GAVE BIRTH TO HER FIRST CHILD
BLOSS LAYOUT IN NINETEEN FIFTY
NINE. SHE RAISED FOUR CHILDREN
INCLUDING THE YOUNGEST RAY LAY
ON WHO TODAY SERVES HIS
COMMUNITY AS THE MAYOR OF
HURON. AND WHO HAS BEEN WORKING
IN ORGANIZING IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY FOR DECADES. IMELDA WAS
A STRONG WOMAN HER WHOLE LIFE
WITH THE SOLID MORAL COMPASS
THAT WOULD PLACE HER IN A
POSITION OF RESPECT WITH THEIR
PEERS IN THE COMMUNITY. A HARD
WORKER AND GREAT COOK SHE WOULD
MAKE LUNCHES FOR ALL THE
RELATIVES WHO WORK IN
AGRICULTURE AND ON OCCASION WE
WOULD HELP OUT AS WELL. LATER
SHE MANAGED THE KITCHEN OF THE
FAMILIES FIRST RESTAURANT AND
WOULD HELP. MAKE THE NEW FAMILY
BUSINESS OF SUCCESS. SHE
MENTORED AND READ. AND REYES
NUMEROUS GRANDCHILDREN THE LAST
ONE WAS. ISABELLA IT'S LA ON
WHO IS NOW ELEVEN YEAR OLD
ELEVEN YEARS OLD I WILL ALWAYS
REMEMBER AMELL THE BECAUSE OF
THE WAY SHE TREATED ME. AND
WHEN I WAS FIRST GEARING UP TO
RUN. SHE HOSTED- ME AND
ACTUALLY THE ENTIRE COMMUNITY
IN HER BACKYARD. AND I GOT TO
TASTE HER WONDERFUL MORNING.
WHICH WAS LIKE FANTASTIC'S AS
SHE WAS DEFINITELY A GREAT COOK
BUT MORE THAN THAT SHE HAD A
GREAT HEART. ISSUES ONE OF
THESE PEOPLE IN THE COMMUNITY
THAT YOU COULD COUNT ON THAT
WOULD BE THERE AND SHE WOULD
JUST TELL YOU LIKE IT WAS. TELL
YOU STRAIGHT UP THIS IS WHAT'S
GOING ON THIS IS WHERE WE NEED
HELP AND THIS IS WHERE WE NEED
YOU. AND SO I'VE ALWAYS
APPRECIATED THAT ABOUT HER AND
I APPRECIATE HER FAMILY. AND
HER SON- I STILL GET TEXT
MESSAGES AND PHONE CALLS FROM
HIM. FIGHTING FOR THE COMMUNITY
AND TRYING TO DO WHAT'S RIGHT
THAT MORAL COMPASS THAT SHE
ADDS THAT SHE HAD HERSELF I
KNOW SHE'S INSTILLED IN ALL OF
OUR CHILDREN BECAUSE I SEE IT.
EVERY SINGLE DAY ANDSO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT THIS
CHAMBER. ADJOURNED IN HER
MEMORY. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MICHELLE S. DR ARAMBULA YOU ARE
ALSO RECOGNIZED ON THIS GERMAN
A MEMBER. I TO RISE TO ADJOURN
IN MEMORY OF A MALE THAT
COCYTUS IMELDA PASSED AWAY
PEACEFULLY ON JUNE TWENTY FIFTH
OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE AT THE AGE
OF EIGHTY FIVE. IMELDA WAS BORN
IN MITCHELL ECONOMY HE CALL AND
IS MADE THE JOURNEY TO THE
UNITED STATES WITH HER HUSBAND
ROME WALDO IN NINETEEN SIXTY
THREE. HER FAMILY SETTLED IN
THE RURAL COMMUNITY OF HERE ON
CALIFORNIA CORRESPONDENT VIA
SHE WAS A WOMAN OF FAITH WITH A
SOLID MORAL COMPASS AND WAS
WELL RESPECTED BY HER FAMILY
HER PEERS AND HER COMMUNITY.
SHE BELIEVED IN THE AMERICAN
DREAM AND OPENED HER HOME TO
THOSE WHO WORK IN THE
AGRICULTURAL FIELDS OF
CALIFORNIA. IMELDA ALSO WORKED
IN THE FIELDS BUT IT WAS OUR
ENTREPRENEURIAL SPIRIT THAT LED
HER TO SUCCESSFULLY OPEN AND
MANAGE THE FAMILY'S FIRST
FAMILY RESTAURANT. IMELDA HAS
ALWAYS BEEN A STRONG ADVOCATE
FOR A COMMUNITIES SHE
PARTICIPATED IN RALLIES AND
COMMUNITY EVENTS ALONGSIDE HER
SON GREATLY ON THE MAYOR OF THE
CITY OF HERE ON. HER LIFE WILL
BE REMEMBERED BY THE GOOD THAT
SHE DID FOR HER COMMUNITY OUR
THOUGHTS AND PRAYERS ARE WITH
HER CHILDREN GRANDCHILDREN
GREAT GRANDCHILDREN FAMILIES
AND FRIENDS I ASKED THAT WE
ADJOURN. IN HER MEMORY TODAY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU DOCTOR
REGULAR THANK YOU MEMBERS.
MOVING TO ANNOUNCEMENTS THE
SESSION SCHEDULE IS AS FOLLOWS
FRIDAY JULY THE SECOND HOLIDAY
INDEPENDENCE DAY. MONDAY JULY
FIFTH FLOOR SESSION IS AT ONE
PM ALL OTHER ITEMS REMAINING
WILL BE PASSED RETAIN ALL
MOTION SHALL BE CONTINUED
SEEING AND HEARING A FOR THE
BUSINESS I'M READY TO ENTERTAIN
A MOTION TO ADJOURN MISTER
COOLEY MOVES. AND MISS CARILLO
SECONDS THAT THIS HOUSE STANDS
ADJOURNED UNTIL MONDAY JULY THE
FIFTH AT ONE PM. WE ARE JERK.